pour tous les leaders mais pour tous les
militants aussi un congrès cela se
prépare bien sûr Michel Rocard veut
d'être un contesté du Congrès a préparer
celui-ci à la manière d'une campagne
électorale avec notamment beaucoup de
voyages en province une manière de
vérifier si le sur le terrain si sa
popularité est bien celle que détecte
les sondages Dominique lor Didier
Daan cette image est trompeuse Michel
rocar ne fête pas le succès de sa motion
au Congrès fédéraux près de 29 % des
mandats mais plus prosaïquement
iltipe à une fte de la r image
symbolique tout de même il y a 3
semaines il évoquait déjà une possible
percé de son courant mais il était loin
d'imaginer un tel score un socialiste
sur TR et recardien dit-il nous voilà
sortie des placards le débat que j'ai
ouvert avec mes amis corédacteurs et
cignataire de la motion a frappé nos
camarades socialistes beaucoup plus
profondément que je ne le pensais
puisque le leur approbation vient et je
demande que que ça aurait donné si on
votait mulret al là camarade de vous
voter en âme et conscience si chacun au
PS amis ou adversaire donne son
explication sur la percé des recardiens
parler vrai pour les uns l'art de
profiter du mécontentement pour d'autres
ces lieutenants mettent en avant un
socialisme qui colle à son temps plus
fait nouveau une présence active sur le
terrain depuis de mois en effet Michel
rard est en campagne multiplie les
déplacements province avec un ob
le façon de vivre il s'agit cette fois
de peaufiner une certaine image
populaire les bains de foule n'effrait
plus Michel Rocard et visiblement le
courant
passe je crois pas beaucoup au sondage
mais je pense que c'est lui qui sera le
mieux placé pour combat de la droite en
1988 on nexplique pas un mouvement
politique par la uniquement par la côte
de d'amour mais je crois que y a de
l'espoir avec lui c'est l' qu' nous faut
pour rassembler le maximum de français
c'est une candidature formidable depuis
1981 du côté des cadres au-delà de
l'analyse politique le ralliment de
nombreux militants aux thèses
recardiennes a des
causes on nous a pas écouté nous l'avons
parfois
regretté je pense que un certain nombre
de militants qui auparavant ne votaient
pas avec ce que l'on appelait l' rocardi
l'ex courouranais nous ont rejoint parce
que ils ont été relativement écurés par
un certain nombre d'événements qui se
sont produits cet été en juin la cerelle
Jospin Fabius et cet été l'affaire
Greenpeace bref chez les recardiens on
exulte oubliant peut-être la simple
logique mathématique 29 % ce n'est pas
la majorité cela dit la montée de Michel
Rocard dans le parti va-t-elle l'inciter
à Toulouse à pousser son avantage ou à
adopter une
plus unitaire tiendra-t-il compte de la
réflexion de Lionel juspin si Michel
rard veut que le parti s'identifie à lui
il doit commencer par s'identifier au
parti